COULD AFTERNOON LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IT'S APRIL TWENTY
FIFTH TWENTY TWENTY TO THE
SENATE SESSION WILL NOW BEGIN
WITH THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA.
ATKINS EIGHTY BAKER PORCHES
BRADFORD CABALLERO CORTESE
VALLEY DODD TORONTO EGGMAN
GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE HERTZBERG
WEST SEVEN FURTADO JONES
KAMLAGER LAYERED LEYVA. LIMÓN
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MEN NEWMAN
NIELSEN A SHOW ABOUT PAN
PORTANTINO ROCK RUBIO SKINNER
STERN NUMBER BY CAL SKI WIENER
WILK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
QUORUM IS SET AS PRESIDENT
MEMBERS IF WE CAN BRING OUR
ATTENTION- FOR THE- PRAYER AND
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE I KNOW THAT
IT'S EXCITING TO BE BACK ON THE
FLOOR IN A REGULAR SEATS BUT
THERE ARE THERE IS ROOM IN THE
BACK TO SEPARATE PEOPLE THAT
JUST CAN'T CAN'T BRING
THEMSELVES TO- PROPER DECORUM
THIS AFTERNOON. FOR THE MEMBERS
AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL
PLEASE. RISE AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO. AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING WILL BE LED THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
BY SENATOR ARCH ALETTA. CENTER
PORTANTINO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
CREATOR GOD WE ASK YOU TO CUT TO
ACCOMPANY US THIS DAY. AS WE
STRIVE TO MAKE THE BEST POSSIBLE
DECISIONS FOR THE GOOD OF YOUR
PEOPLE. BE WITH US IN OUR TIMES
OF PHYSICAL NEED AND SPIRITUAL
TRIAL. WHEN WE ARE TEMPTED TO
FEAR AND DOUBT. IN OUR QUEST FOR
MORE JUST ORDER. WHEN WE ARE
TEMPTED TO DISCOURAGEMENT BE
WITH US IN OUR ENCOUNTERS WITH
THE POOR AND NEEDY OF OUR TIME.
WE ARE WHEN WE ARE TEMPTED TO
GROW WEARY. IN OUR DEBATES WITH
PERSONS WHO DISAGREE WITH US. WE
ARE WHEN WE ARE TEMPTED TO
MISUNDERSTANDING. BE WITH US IN
OUR SUCCESSES AS A GOVERNANCE
BODY. WHEN WE MAY BE TEMPTED TO
SELF SATISFACTION. GRACIOUS AND
MERCIFUL GOD STRENGTHEN US ON
OUR JOURNEY OF LEADERSHIP. THAT
WE MAY WITNESS TO THE VALUE OF
HUMBLE SERVICE FOR ALL THOSE WHO
PUT THEIR TRUST IN OUR WORK.
OCELOTS ORDERED ME WE ASK THIS
IN YOUR NAME AMEN. SANDERS
LADIES AND GENTLE PUT YOUR HAND
OVER YOUR HEART AS WE HONOR OUR
FLAG AND OUR MEN AND WOMEN WHO
SERVED OUR GREAT COUNTRY I
PLEDGE.
THANK YOU GUESTS AND MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR THERE
ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. WE HAVE
ONE MOTION THIS MORNING- ARE
THAT THIS AFTERNOON WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE SENATE JOURNALS
FOR THE WEEK OF APRIL EIGHTEENTH
THROUGH THE TWENTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. WILL BE APPROVED AND
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
MEMBERS ANYBODY ELSE MEET
WISHING TO BE RECOGNIZED UNDER
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
. SAYING NONE WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE MEMBERS. WE'RE GONNA
TAKE UP SECOND READING FILE
FIRST SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN SIXTEEN
WITH AMENDMENTS TWELVE NINETY
EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS FOURTEEN
SIXTY TWO WITH AMENDMENTS EIGHT
FIFTY THREE WITH AMENDMENTS NINE
SEVENTY FOUR WITH AMENDMENTS
NINE EIGHTY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL NINE NINE
READING WILL BE DEEMED READ
MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON TO THE
THIRD READING FILE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE HAVE- FOR ITEMS ON
STATE SENATE THIRD READING TODAY
ITEMS FORTY. FORTY FIVE. SEVENTY
EIGHT AND SEVENTY NINE THERE
WILL BE ONE ITEM ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AFTER THAT. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO SENATE. FILE ITEM
FORTY SENATE BILL. NINE THIRTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR HERTZBERG.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF WE CAN
BRING OUR ATTENTION TO THE FLOOR
PLEASE WE HAVE AN AUTHOR
PRESENTING. CENTERS FOR YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. AND I'M SORRY CENTER
HERTZBERG THE SECOND TRIAL READ
FIRST. SENATE BILL NINE THIRTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR HERTZBERG AN
ACT RELATING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
. NOW CENTERS FOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I KNOW I'M A BIT OF A
HISTORIAN AROUND THIS PLACE BUT
IT INFORMS MY INTEREST IN THIS
WORK. IN NINETEEN SIXTY THREE IS
CALIFORNIA WAS EXPANDING RAPIDLY
GOV THEN GOVERNOR PAT BROWN SAW
THESE EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGES
AMONG LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CALLED
SPHERES OF INFLUENCE. TOGETHER
WITH CHECK MARKS AND DON CORTESE
FROM SAN JOSE AND WE'RE NOW THE
CO AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE IS HIS
SON- THIS LASKO BILL BEGAN TO
SET FORTH THE STRUCTURE AS TO
HOW THE GROWING NUMBERS OF
SPECIAL DISTRICTS THE GROWING
NUMBERS OF CITIES. AND THE FOR
THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES WITH
INTER RELATE AS THEY DEALT WITH
ISSUES AFFECTING THEIR
RESPECTIVE JURISDICTIONS AND
GOVERNANCE. THAT RESULTED IN A
SERIES OF LAWS OVER MANY MANY
YEARS WHICH CREATED SOME
CHALLENGES THE LAST CALL LAW AND
WHEN I CAME TO GOVERNMENT- I
SPENT FOUR YEARS WORKING WITH
THE COMMISSION WE SPENT MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS THE MAYOR OF SAN
DIEGO WAS THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMISSION. TO BEGIN TO REWRITE
THE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE
PAGE LAUGH CALL LAW AND TO
CREATE SOME ORDER AROUND THE
PROCESS IT PASSED THE
LEGISLATURE. AND IT BECAME KNOWN
AS THE CORTESE KNOCKS HERTZBERG
LOCAL GOVERNMENT REORGANISATION
ACT OF TWO THOUSAND. SENATOR
CORTESE FROM SAN JOSE INDICATES
THAT APPARENTLY THESE THINGS ARE
ALL OVER THE STATE PROBABLY IF I
EVER PUBLISHED A BOOK. IT
PROBABLY HAS THE MOST NUMBER OF
ISSUES OF ANYTHING THAT'S EVER
BEEN PUBLISHED. BUT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ALL AROUND THE STATE AGAIN WE
HAVE FIVE THOUSAND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS SCHOOL DISTRICTS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN CALIFORNIA FIVE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA. SO NOW. NO
FACE. TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
LITTLE HOOVER. COMES ALONG AN
ISSUE A REPORT AND- SOME WERE
DISTRICTS AND THE ROLE AND LAUGH
COAST. PROCESS THE REPORT
HIGHLIGHTED THE COMPLICATED
INCONSISTENT SET OF RULES THAT
HAVE OCCURRED OVER A NUMBER OF.
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS I WAS
ABLE TO CHAIR THAT COMMITTEE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE FOR A
COUPLE OF YEARS AND WE CALLED
THE COMMITTEE OF EXCEPTIONS
BECAUSE EVERY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
WOULD COME IN. AND WANT TO MAKE
AN EXCEPTION TO LOK TO LAUGH
COED SOMETIMES THEY RUN INCLINED
INTO EACH OTHER. SO AS A RESULT
OF THEY THESE INCONSISTENCIES
THE SERVICE A DETERRENT TO LAUGH
COAST TO INITIATE DISSOLUTIONS
OF VARIOUS LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES IN THE FIRST PLACE. AND
SO FOLLOWING THE REPORT CAL LAST
CALL THE AGENCY OF ALL A LOT OF
CLOTHES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ALL FIFTY EIGHT LEFT
GOES IN CALIFORNIA. PUT TOGETHER
A THREE YEAR WORKING GROUP SO
HERE YOU HAVE FOUR YEARS OF
WORKING ON THIS UNDER PAT BROWN
FOUR YEARS OF WORKING ON THIS
BACK IN THE TWO THOUSANDS. AND
NOW ANOTHER EFFORT OF WITH LIFE
COACH AS A RESULT OF THIS FOR
THREE REFERENCE. IS NOT
SOMETHING WITH THE BILL WAS
INVENTED YESTERDAY BUT A LOT OF
STAKEHOLDERS A LOT OF
DISCUSSION. AND THIS THREE YEAR
REPORT BASICALLY INITIATED. A
DISSOLUTION OF SPECIAL DISTRICTS
WITH A TWENTY FIVE PERCENT.
PASSAGE RATE UNDER THREE
CONDITIONS. THE TERMINATION
REQUEST ACTIONS DOCUMENTED BY A
MUNICIPAL SERVICE REVIEW THE
DISTURBING QUESTION IS GRANTED A
MINIMUM OF TWELVE MONTHS
REMEDIATION. AND THE SECOND
TWENTY ONE DAY PUBLIC HEARING.
PROCESS THIS IS BEEN SUPPORTED
BY ALL THE LEFT COAST IT'S A
FULL CIRCLE OF THIS EFFORT OVER
MANY MANY YEARS IN THIS
COMPLICATED AREA OF GOVERNMENT.
AS TO HOW WE ALL INTER RELATE
WITH EACH OTHER AS WE MASS MORE
AND MORE LOCAL GOVERNMENTAL
ENTITIES. I. ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. THANK
YOU SIR HEARD MEMBERS ANY DISK.
OR ON FOR ITEM FORTY YOU NEED
TO. OR TO. SCENE NONE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BECKER AYE FORGES AYE
BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO AYE FOR
TESTING AYE DOLLY AYE DODD. I
YOU'RE AWESOME FIVE EGGMAN AYE
GLAZER. FIVE GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE
. HERTZBERG I REQUEST SOME HI
FURTADO I JONES I KAMLAGER I
LAYERED. I LEYVA AYE LIMÓN I
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ AYE MIN AYE
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A CHOI BOGUE
I CAN AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH. I
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN HI I'M
BURKE. I Y. CASKEY I WIENER AYE
WILK. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FORTY
FIVE SENATOR JONES MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR BY
SENATOR RICK JONES AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC CONTRACTS.
CENTER JONES THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
FIFTY FOUR AUTHORIZES A CITY OR
COUNTY TO USE DESIGN BUILD
CONTRACTING PROCESS FOR PROJECTS
TO COMPLY WITH FEDERAL ADA
REGULATIONS THIS BILL WILL
CREATE A MORE EFFICIENT AND
AFFORDABLE WAY TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF ADA COMPLIANT
GOVERNMENT BUILDINGS IN
CALIFORNIA. I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER JONES
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NON
MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE IS THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. ALL EVEN. SORRY
NO. THANK YOU MEMBERS ARE MOVING
ON A FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT.
SENATE RESOLUTION EIGHTY ONE
CENTER LA MON. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE RESOLUTION EIGHTY
ONE BY SENATOR LIMÓN RELATIVE TO
SEXUAL ASSAULT. CEREMONY THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT SR EIGHTY ONE WHICH
RECOGNISES THIS WEDNESDAY APRIL
TWENTY SEVENTH AS A DAY.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY PEOPLE ALL
AND- GENDERS AND AGES HAVE BEEN
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT. ONE
IN TWO WOMEN AND ONE IN FIVE MEN
HAVE EXPERIENCED SEXUAL VIOLENCE
OTHER THAN RAPE IN THEIR
LIFETIME. SEXUAL ASSAULTS CAN BE
HEAVY MEDIA AND LONG LASTING
CONSEQUENCES INCLUDING PTSD
SUBSTANCE ABUSE MAJOR DEPRESSION
HOMELESSNESS EATING DISORDERS
LOW SELF ESTEEM AND SUICIDE. IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT A MAN
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED AN EIGHTEEN
YEAR OLD WOMAN THE ITALIAN
SUPREME COURT OVERTURNED HIS
CONVICTION BECAUSE SHE WORE
TIGHT JEANS. THEY ARGUED THAT
BECAUSE SHE MAY HAVE HAD TO HELP
HIM REMOVE THEM SHE CONSENTED.
THE WOMEN OF THE ITALIAN
PARLIAMENT IMMEDIATELY
PROTESTING PROTESTED BY WEARING
JEANS TO WORK INSPIRING DENIM
DAYS AROUND THE WORLD. IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE CALIFORNIA TO FILL
THE PROMISE OF DENIM DAY BY
ENACTING ABNINE THIRTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SABRINA
CERVANTES TO PROHIBIT A
SURVIVOR'S MANNER OF DRESS FROM
SERVING AS EVIDENCE OF CONSENT
IN SEXUAL ASSAULT CASES. VICTIM
BLAMING IT ALL TO HARM COMMON
AND HARMFUL ATTITUDES ALLOW
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND RAPE CRIMES
TO PERSIST. SURVIVORS DESERVE TO
BE TREATED WITH DIGNITY
COMPASSION AND RESPECT WE MUST
CONTINUE OUR COMMITMENT TO
FOSTER HEALING AND INCREASE
PUBLIC UNDERSTANDING OF THIS
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM. I HOPE YOU
WILL ALL JOIN ME AND WEARING
JEANS ON WEDNESDAY TO HELP
COMMUNICATE THE MESSAGE THAT
THERE IS NO EXCUSE AND NEVER AN
INVITATION TO COMMIT RAPE. THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CEREMONY
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
SENATOR DELHI. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE ACROSS THE WORLD
PARTICIPATE IN DENIM DAY BY
WEARING JEANS WITH A PURPOSE TO
SUPPORT SURVIVORS AND EDUCATE
THEMSELVES AND OTHERS ABOUT ALL
FORMS OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE. THEY
DIDN'T A STORY BEGAN IN ITALY IN
NINETEEN NINETY TWO WHEN AN
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD GIRL WAS RAPED
BY A FORTY FIVE YEAR OLD.
DRIVING INSTRUCTOR WHO WAS
TAKING HER TO HER FIRST DRIVING
LESSON. HE TOOK HER TO AN
ISOLATED ROLE ROAD. PULLED HER
OUT OF THE CAR AND REMOVED HER
JEANS AND FORCEFULLY RAPED HER.
SHE REPORTS THAT THE RAPE AND
THE PERPETRATOR IS ARRESTED AND
PROSECUTED. HE IS THEN CONVICTED
OF RAPE AND SENTENCED TO JAIL.
YEARS LATER HE APPEALED THE
CONVICTION CLAIMING THAT HE HAD.
THAT IT HAD BEEN CONSENT
CONSENSUAL SEX I TALLIEN SUPREME
COURT. OVERTURNED THE CONVICTION
AND THE PERPETRATOR WAS RELEASED
. A STUDENT FROM THE COURT
ARGUED THAT BECAUSE THE VICTIM
WAS WEARING VERY TIGHT JEANS.
SHE HAD HELPED TO REMOVE THEM
AND BY REMOVING THE JEANS IT WAS
NOT RAPE BUT CONSENSUAL SEX.
THIS BECAME KNOWN THROUGHOUT
ITALY AS THE JEAN ALIBI. IN RAGE
BY THE VERDICT THE WOMEN AND I
TALLIEN PARLIAMENT LAUNCHED A
PROTEST WEARING JEANS ON THE
STEPS OF THE SUPREME COURT. THE
PROTEST WAS PICKED UP. BY
INTERNATIONAL MEDIA WHICH
INSPIRED THE CALIFORNIA SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY TO DO THE SAME ON
THE STEPS OF THE CAPITOL IN
SACRAMENTO. ATTY OKAY Z.
GEOGHAN'S EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
PEACE OVER VIOLENCE SAW THIS IN
THE MEDIA AND THOUGHT EVERYONE
SHOULD BE WEARING JEANS TO
PROTEST ALL MYTHS. ABOUT WOMEN
AND GIRLS WHO ARE RAPED. DENIM
DAY IN LA WAS BORN THE FIRST IN
AND DAY IN LA EVENT WAS HELD IN
APRIL OF NINETEEN NINETY NINE
AND CONTINUES AT LEAST ANNUALLY
SINCE. THE POINT OF THIS
RESOLUTION SR EIGHTY ONE.
PROMOTES THE WELLNESS AND
PREVENTION OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE
INCLUDING APPOINT APPOINTMENTS
IS RATE. STRANGER RAPE SEXUAL
ASSAULT BY AN ISSUE BUT BY AN
INTIMATE PARTNER GANG RAPE
INCEST SERIAL RAPE. SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CHILD SEXUAL ABUSE
SEX TRAFFICKING AND STALKING
THAT IS IN THIS RESOLUTION. IT
IS CRUEL TO HOLD PERPETRATORS IS
CRUCIAL TO HOLD PERPETRATORS
RESPONSIBLE FOR SEXUAL ATTACKS
AND PREVENTION OF SEXUAL
VIOLENCE AT EVERY OPPORTUNITY.
HARMFUL ATTITUDES ABOUT RAPE AND
SEXUAL ASSAULT ALLOW THESE
CRIMES TO RESIST ALLOWING
SURVIVORS TO BE RE VICTIMIZED.
THREE VICTIMS BLAMING ATTITUDE
SOMETIMES UNRESPONSIVE
GOVERNMENT SYSTEMS THAT IS
ACTUALLY IN THIS RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS I THINK THE HYPOCRISY IS
THAT WE'RE WE'RE TAKING UP S. R.
EIGHTY ONE WHEN JUST WEEKS AGO.
CURRENTLY THE MOST EGREGIOUS
FORMS OF HUMIC XING TRAFFICKING
INVOLVING SEX ACTS IN THE COURSE
OF CHILDREN FOR SEX ACTS IS
DEFINED AS NON VIOLENT IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. VICTIMS
WERE EXPLOITED BY SEN
TRAFFICKERS WHO FORCED THEM TO
SELL THEIR BODIES. BORDER
TRAFFICKERS FINANCIAL GAIN.
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS ARE
FREQUENTLY FORCED TO HAVE SEX
WITH UPWARDS OF FIFTEEN
STRANGERS A DAY AND FACING
BEATINGS ON THE HANDS OF THEIR
TRAFFICKERS. IN CALIFORNIA THAT
IS NOT. A VIOLENT CRIME TODAY.
SB TEN FORTY TWO WHICH FELL
PASSAGE. IN THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE JUST WEEKS AGO. WHAT
FURTHER HOLD PERPETRATORS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR CRIMES AND
PREVENT WOMEN FROM BEING BIG
COMING VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. SOME MEMBERS ON
THIS FLOOR VOTED AGAINST THAT
BILL. IT IS STILL IN THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE TODAY WE CAN
BRING THAT BILL UP UNDER
SPECIALS. TO BE HEARD AGAIN THAT
WILL SECURE OUT AND WE'RE FOR
THIS BILL TODAY YOU SHOULD BE
BUILDING VOTING FOR SP TEN FORTY
TWO. WHICH WOULD MAKE IT A CRIME
IN CALIFORNIA- A FELONY CRIME.
IF YOU SEX TRAFFIC SOMEBODY
INNER DALY UNFORTUNATELY I NEED
TO STICK TO THE MERITS OF THIS I
WOULD I WOULD URGE YOU TO VOTE
FOR THIS BILL AND ALSO VOTE FOR
SB TEN FORTY TWO. THANK YOU SIR
. CENTER SKINNER WILL BE
FOLLOWED BY CENTER RUBIO SINNERS
CAN. THANK YOU SO MUCH- MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AYE REYES ON
BEHALF OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF S. R. EIGHTY ONE. NOW
AS I STRUGGLE TO FIND MY GLASSES
- NO ONE I THINK ALL OF US KNOW
THIS NO ONE INVITES HARASSMENT
ABUSE ASSAULT OR RAPE. EFFORT
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT OUR WARDROBE
DECISIONS ARE OR OTHER
ACTIVITIES WE DO NOT INVITE THAT
TYPE OF ASSAULT AND THIS IS THE
POINT OF DENIM DAY. WE ALL KNOW
HAVE THE HIGH NUMBER OF SEXUAL
ASSAULTS BUT WE MAY NOT REALIZE
THE IMPLICATIONS OF THAT HIGH
NUMBER. ONE STATE FOUND THAT 76%
OF INCARCERATED WOMEN IN THAT
STATE WERE SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL
ABUSE BY THE AGE OF THIRTEEN
SEVENTY. 6% WE ALSO KNOW THAT
MANY MANY RAPES AND SEXUAL
ASSAULTS GO UNREPORTED. THAT THE
SHAME RELATED TO THIS OR THE
FEELING THAT SOMEHOW HI THE
PERSON WHO WAS ASSAULTED THAT
SOMEHOW WE CONTRIBUTED TO IT
HAPPENING IT WAS OUR FAULT WE
THEN DON'T REPORT. NO THIS
PREJUDICE ALSO PROVIDED LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR A LONG TIME AND
WE FOUND THAT EVEN WHEN SEXUAL
ASSAULTS AND RAPES WERE REPORTED
THEY WERE NOT PRIORITIZED FOR
ENFORCEMENT AND THE GREAT
EXAMPLE OF WHAT THAT WAS. THOSE
PEOPLE WHO WERE RAPED WHO WENT
IN TO THE HOSPITAL AND GOT THE
WHOLE KIT WHICH THE WHOLE
EVIDENCE WHICH IS CALLED A RAPE
KIT. THOSE RAPE KITS WERE LEFT
ON SHELVES EVIDENCE SHOWS FOR
YEARS UNTESTED. WE'VE CHANGE
THAT NOW THE LEGISLATURE IS
TAKEN OUT ON WE'RE FINDING OUR
POLICE DEPARTMENTS WE ARE MADE
IT A PRIORITY. AND WE ARE SEEING
AN INCREASE NOT ONLY IN. THE THE
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS BUT ALSO IN
THE CONVICTIONS THE CATCHING
EVERY PERSON THE CONVICTIONS.
AND WE HAVE TO ELIMINATE THESE
TYPES OF PREJUDICES IN THESE
ATTITUDES IN ORDER FOR ANYONE
AND EVERYONE WHO EXPERIENCES A
SEXUAL ASSAULT TO FEEL NO SHAME
ABOUT REPORTING IT AND REALLY
THAT IS THE POINT OF DENIM DAY.
SO I VERY MUCH STAND IN SUPPORT
AND ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER SKINNER CENTER RUBIO WILL
BE FOLLOWED BY CENTER COME
LONGER CENTER RUBIO. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY I
RISE ON BEHALF OF THE JEWISH
CAUCUS IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR S.
R. EIGHTY ONE. WHICH RECOGNIZES
APRIL TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AS DOWN ON DAY IN CALIFORNIA
. TODAY WE WERE DONE- TO SHOW
THAT WE STAND WITH SEXUAL
ASSAULT SURVIVORS IN THE WOMEN
GIRLS AND OTHER INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE BEEN ASSAULTED ABUSED OR
HARASSED. JUDAISM TEACHES THAT
ALL PEOPLE ARE SACRED BEINGS TO
BE PROTECTED AND NURTURED AND
THAT TO ACT AGAINST HIM AND
VIOLENCE. IS TO ACT AGAINST THE
DIVINE AND THE JEWISH TRADITION
TO COST ANOTHER PAIN OR MORAL
DEGRADATION IS A CAN TO MURDER.
WHEN WE REFUSED TO CONFRONT
THESE BEHAVIORS WE ARE
COMPLICIT. ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE
A BYSTANDER. AS STATED EARLIER
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
WAS PROUD TO SUPPORT A. B. NINE
THIRTY NINE WHICH PROHIBITS THE
SURVIVORS A TIRE TO BE USED AS
EVIDENCE OF CONSENT IN SEXUAL
ASSAULT CASES. THE CHANGE WAS
LONG OVERDUE AGAIN THERE IS
NEVER AN EXCUSE TO BE HARASSED
ABUSED ASSAULTED. OR RATE.
CHANGING THE SOCIAL NORMS THAT
ALLOW THIS KIND OF BEHAVIOR IS
IMPORTANT FOR CIVIL SOCIETY AND
MAKING THIS CHANGE REQUIRES US
TO CONTINUE TO WORK TO EDUCATE
EVERYONE FROM CHILDREN FRIENDS
FAMILIES THIS WEDNESDAY WE
INVITE EVERYONE TO WEAR DENIM.
IT IS A REALLY GOOD DAY TO SHOW
THAT WE MUST SEND A STRONG
MESSAGE THAT WE STAND WITH
SURVIVORS AND VICTIMS FOR THIS
REASON I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR S. R. EIGHTY
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO CENTER COME LONGER. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT AS VICE CHAIR
OF THE BLACK CAUCUS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SR EIGHTY ONE DENIM
DAY. ONE OF THE STATED PURPOSES
OF DENIM DAY IS TO EDUCATE
OTHERS ABOUT SEXUAL VIOLENCE. A
LITTLE HISTORY THAT SOMETIMES
GETS OVERLOOKED IN THESE
DISCUSSIONS IS THAT DURING THE
EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS MOST STATES
EXCLUDED BLACK WOMEN BOTH FREE
AND ENSLAVED FROM WORK RATE LAWS
. IT WAS NOT UNTIL EIGHTEEN
SIXTY ONE THAT A BLACK WOMAN
COULD EVEN FILE RAPE CHARGES
AGAINST A WHITE MAN. BLACK WOMEN
ARE ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE TO
SEXUAL VIOLENCE DUE TO MULTIPLE
SOURCES OF OPPRESSION. MORE THAN
20% OF BLACK WOMEN ARE RAPED
DURING OUR LIFETIMES. A LOT A
HIGHER SHARE THAN AMONG WOMEN
OVERALL. IN THE UNITED STATES
38% OF BLACK WOMEN EXPERIENCED
SEXUAL VIOLENCE OTHER THAN RAPE
. ONE IN FOUR BLACK GIRLS WILL
BE SEXUALLY ABUSED BEFORE THE
AGE OF EIGHTEEN. AMONG STUDENTS
11% OF BLACK GIRLS IN A NATIONAL
HIGH SCHOOL SAMPLE REPORTED
HAVING BEEN RATE. 40% OF CONFIRM
SEX TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS IN THE
UNITED STATES ARE BLACK. ALL OF
THESE STATISTICS ARE EVEN HIGHER
FOR BLACK TRANS WOMEN AND FOR
OUR BLACK BOYS THEY ARE ALSO
RAPED AND SEXUALLY ASSAULTED AT
ALARMING RATES. BLACK BOYS FIRST
SEXUAL ENCOUNTER ON AVERAGE IS
AT AGE NINE OR TEN FROM AN OLDER
WOMAN. AND ONE IN SIX BLACK BOYS
HAVE SUFFERED SEXUAL ABUSE.
THESE ACTS ARE OFTEN MINIMIZED
AND IN FACT SEEN AS RITE OF
PASSAGE. BUT OUR BLACK BOYS ARE
VICTIMS JUST LIKE OUR BLACK
GIRLS. BECAUSE OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS UNIQUE HISTORY OF
RACIST AND SEXIST VICTIMIZATION
THE BLACK COMMUNITY HAS AN EVEN
HARDER TIME THAN OTHERS DEALING
WITH RAPE AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
THIS PREVENTS SURVIVORS FROM
GETTING HELP AND THE COMMUNITY
FROM ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES
EFFECTIVELY AND HONESTLY.
HOWEVER MOMENTS LIKE DENIM DAY
INCREASE THE VISIBILITY OF THESE
IMPORTANT ISSUES AND AMPLIFY
AMPLIFY THE VOICES OF ALL OF OUR
SURVIVORS. THE GOAL IS TO LEAD
TO CHANGE AND LAWS AND ATTITUDES
AS WE ALL CONTINUE TO STRIVE FOR
EQUITABLE JUSTICE COLLEAGUES I
ASK. FOR YOUR AYE VOTE FOR S. R.
EIGHTY ONE. MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
OTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON
SR EIGHTY ONE FILE ITEM SEVENTY
EIGHT ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE CENTER ALONE
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND COLLEAGUES
TO FOR ALL YOUR WORDS AND
EXPERIENCES AND BACKGROUNDS ON
WHY THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT.
DAY TO RECOGNIZE THANK YOU ALL
OF THOSE WHO ARE WEARING DENIM
NOW- IT TO RECOGNIZE THIS AND
THOSE WHO WILL WEAR IT ON
WEDNESDAY- WE ARE SENDING A
MESSAGE NOT JUST TO MEN AND
WOMEN WHO HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY
SEXUAL ASSAULT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT GLOBALLY. SO WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CEREMONY
MEMBERS SENATE RESOLUTION EIGHTY
ONE QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING NO OBJECTION THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED HIGHS
THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO. MEMBERS
ARE MOVING ON A FILE ITEM
SEVENTY NINE S. R. SENATE
RESOLUTION EIGHTY TWO. BY
SENATOR DORADO SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE RESOLUTION EIGHTY
TWO BY SENATOR ALSO RELATIVE TO
THE COMMEMORATION OF THE
ANNIVERSARY OF THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE OF NINETEEN FIFTEEN TO
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE. CENTER
DRAWS THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
IT'S AN HONOR TO PRESENT SENATE
RESOLUTION EIGHTY TWO TO
COMMEMORATE THE ANNIVERSARY OF
THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE BOTH AS A
MEMBER OF THE ARMENIAN CAUCUS
AND AS CHAIR OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS THIS SYSTEMATIC AND
PREMEDITATED GENOCIDE.
OFFICIALLY BEGAN ON APRIL TWENTY
FOURTH NINETEEN FIFTEEN WHEN
OVER ONE AND A HALF MILLION
ARMENIAN MEN WOMEN AND CHILDREN
WERE SLAUGHTERED OR MARCHED TO
THEIR DEATHS IN AN EFFORT TO
ANNIHILATE THE ARMENIAN NATION.
TODAY WE ALSO MARKED THE FIRST
APRIL TWENTY FOURTH ANNIVERSARY
SINCE THE U. S. AND PRESIDENT
BIDEN RECOGNIZED THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE. PRESIDENT BIDEN
REJECTED TURKEY'S GAG RULE.
THROUGHOUT HISTORY HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS OF PLAGUED OUR WORLD
DIVERSE PEOPLE OF STRUGGLE TO
SURVIVE IN A WORLD OFTEN FILLED
WITH FEAR AND HATRED AND
VIOLENCE WITHOUT UNIVERSAL
RESPECT FOR HUMAN RIGHTS THE
WORLD CANNOT ACHIEVE PEACE. THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA STANDS ON
THE RIGHT SIDE OF JUSTICE IT IS
HOME TO THOSE WHO ARE TORN FROM
THEIR HOMELANDS. THE ARMENIAN
STORY IS PART OF THE GREATER
STORY OF CALIFORNIA. THAT'S WHY
I AM SO PROUD TO REPRESENT
LITTLE ARMENIA AND MY DISTRICT
WHERE SO MANY ARMENIANS HAVE
CALLED HOME FOR DECADES. TODAY
OUR SYMPATHY GOES TO ALL THE
SURVIVORS OF THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE AND THEIR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN. AND ESPECIALLY TO
THE NEARLY HALF A MILLION PEOPLE
OF ARMENIAN DESCENT WERE PART OF
OUR STATE. TODAY WAIT KNOWLEDGE
THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND
DEDICATION OF THE DESCENDANTS OF
THE GENOCIDE VICTIMS WHO
CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR JUSTICE
AND PLAY A VITAL ROLE IN
CALIFORNIA'S ADVANCEMENT. THE
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA WILL
NOT LET THEIR HISTORY BANISH.
CONGRESSMAN'S THAT THE US
RECOGNITION OF THE I'M ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE IS TRANSLATED INTO
ACTUAL INSISTING POLICY WE MUST
OPEN THE CHALLENGE ANY ATTEMPT
AT DENIAL WE MUST COUNTER
THREATS TO THE ARMENIAN PEOPLE
AND WE MUST ACTIVELY SUPPORT THE
FOR SURVIVAL OF ARTS ACT AND
THE- SECURITY OF ARMENIA. I WANT
TO THANK THE SENATOR FROM
KANNADA FLINT RIDGE FOR THE
LEADERSHIP ROLE HE HAS PLAYED IN
THE SENATE. IN KEEPING THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE IN THE MINDS
OF ALL PEOPLE AND I WANT TO END
WITH A VERY SHORT WRITING BY
WILLIAM SAROYAN WHO IS A WRITER
POET FROM MY HOME AREA FRESNO.
QUOTE I SHOULD LIKE TO SEE ANY
POWER OF THE WORLD DESTROY THIS
RACE THIS SMALL TRIBE OF
UNIMPORTANT PEOPLE WHOSE WARS
HAVE ALL BEEN FOUGHT AND LOST
WHO STRUCTURES HAVE CRUMBLED.
LITERATURE IS ON READ MUSIC AS
AN HEARD AND PRAYERS FOR MORE
ANSWERS. MY HEAD DESTROY ARMENIA
SEE IF YOU CAN DO IT. SEND THEM
INTO THE DESERT WITHOUT BREAD OR
WATER. IN THEIR HOMES AND
CHURCHES THIS SEE IF THEY WILL
NOT LAUGH AND SING AND PRAY
AGAIN. FOR ONE TWO OF THEM MADE
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD. YEAH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER DRAWS- SENATOR
PORTANTINO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS SEN I
RISE- AT FIRST TO COMPLEMENT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES ON
HER ELOQUENT- WORDS IN QUOTING
WILLIAM SAROYAN SO WONDERFULLY
TODAY- I RISE IN SUPPORT OF S.
R. EIGHTY TWO REAFFIRMING
CALIFORNIA'S RECOGNITION OF THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE. DESIGNATING
THE YEAR OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AND THE MONTH OF APRIL FOR
COMMEMORATION. EVERY YEAR ON
APRIL TWENTY FOURTH THREE
REMEMBER THE ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION ARMENIANS HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF GREEKS ASSYRIANS
AND OTHER CHRISTIANS MASSACRED
BY THE OTTOMAN TURKISH EMPIRE
FROM NINETEEN FIFTEEN. TO
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE. WHEN YOU
GO BACK TO YOUR OFFICES THE
LEGISLATIVE ARMENIAN CAUCUS
FOUNDATION WILL BE GIVING YOU A
BOOK TITLED MY NAME IS RM BY
WILLIAM SAROYAN- ALLUDED TO BY
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LA. PLEASE
READ IT AT YOUR LEISURE AND
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE ARMENIAN
PEOPLE FROM THIS GREAT WRITER.
ON APRIL TWENTY FOURTH NINETEEN
FIFTEEN. TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
ARMENIAN POLITICAL RELIGIOUS AND
EDUCATIONAL AND INTELLECTUAL
LEADERS WERE ARRESTED IN IN
STUMBLE BY THE LEADERS OF THE
OTTOMAN EMPIRE. THEY WERE
DEPORTED TO THE INTERIOR THE
COMPANY COUNTRY AND MURDERED. ON
THAT SAME DAY FIVE THOUSAND MEN
WOMEN AND CHILDREN WERE ROUNDED
UP AND SLAUGHTERED ON THE
STREETS AND IN THEIR HOMES. OVER
THE NEXT THREE YEARS THE TURKISH
GOVERNMENT ORDERED THE
DEPORTATION OF THE REMAINING
ARMENIAN POPULATION IN THE
OTTOMAN EMPIRE. TO CONCENTRATION
CAMPS IN THE DESERT OF DINNERS
OR- WOMEN AND CHILDREN WERE
FORCED TO WALK OVER MOUNTAINS
AND THROUGH DESERT. WITHOUT FOOD
AND WITHOUT WATER. THEY WERE
FREQUENTLY STRIPPED NAKED AND
ABUSED THE INTENTION OF THE
OTTOMANS WAS COMPLETE
OBLITERATION OF THE ARMENIAN
NATION. NOT ONLY IN THE NATION
BUT ALSO ANY MEMORY OF THE
ARMENIAN PEOPLE. BACK IN
NINETEEN FIFTEEN THE WORD
GENOCIDE THE WORD DIDN'T EVEN
EXIST. HE WENT CONVENTION ON THE
PREVENTION OF PUNISHMENT OF THE
CRIME OF GENOCIDE WAS ONLY
ADOPTED IN NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT
IN THE AFTERMATH OF THE
HOLOCAUST. AFTER A SPEECH IN
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE ADOLF
HITLER SAID. AFTER ALL WHO
SPEAKS TODAY OF THE ANNIHILATION
OF THE ARMENIANS. THE ANSWER
THAT WE GIVE TODAY IS WE DO.
ARMENIANS CONTINUE TO LIVE AND
PROSPER IN ARMENIA ARTSAKH AND
THEN THE ASPER AND IN CALIFORNIA
. CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO THE
LARGEST ARMENIAN AMERICAN
POPULATION IN THE US AND MANY
ARE THE CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN OF SURVIVORS OF
THE GENOCIDE. THAT ENHANCE
CULTURAL DIVERSITY MAKE ARTISTIC
ECONOMIC AND ACADEMIC
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR GREAT STATE
. A HUNDRED AND SEVEN YEARS
AFTER THE GENOCIDE THE TWO
SUCCESSOR STATES OF THE GENOCIDE
PERPETRATORS TURKEY AND
AZERBAIJAN CONTINUOUSLY TRY TO
IMPLEMENT THEIR GENOCIDAL AGENDA
TOWARD THE ARMENIANS IN THE
REPUBLIC OF ARMENIA AND ARTSAKH.
WELL ARMENIAN R. TUCKER STILL
RECOVERING FROM THE TWENTY
TWENTY FORTY FOUR DAY WAR THE
SHOOTINGS AND SMALL SCALE
ATTACKS DO NOT STOP. EVEN TO
THIS DAY. DURING MY LAST VISIT
TO ARMENIA IN NOVEMBER I WAS
HONORED TO VISIT ARTSAKH AND WAS
DEEPLY AFFECTED BY MY TIME THERE
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO WITNESS
THE CONSEQUENCES OF THE
UNPROVOKED WAR. I SAW DESTROYED
HOMES SCHOOLS RIDDLED WITH BLOOD
WITH BULLET HOLES SCHOOLS.
RIDDLED WITH BULLET HOLES WERE
TODAY YOUNG STUDENTS PLAY IN THE
BACKYARD TWO HUNDRED YARDS AWAY
FROM AZARI CAMPS HOSPITALS AND
CHURCHES LEVELED BY OURS JERRY
SHELLING. I MET WITH LOCAL
VILLAGERS ON THE BORDER SOLDIERS
AND SURVIVORS OF THE WAR MANY OF
WHOM THEMSELVES OUR GRAND
CHILDREN OF THOSE WHO SURVIVED
THE GENOCIDE. THIS IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE INSTEAD OF BEING ABLE TO
HEAL FROM THE TRAUMA. AND FORCE
FOCUS ON REBUILDING FOR THE
FUTURE GENERATIONS THEY'VE BEEN
FORCED TO RELIVE THEIR MEMORIES
OF THE CYCLE OF
INTERGENERATIONAL TRAUMA
CONTINUES. THESE MORE RECENT
EVENTS ON THE SUNY CAN ARTS OCT
BORDER MAKE ALL OF US REALIZE
THAT THE AGGRESSION THE VIOLENCE
TOWARDS THE ARMENIAN PEOPLE HAS
NOT STOPPED. YES LAST YEAR
PRESIDENT BIDEN OFFICIALLY
RECOGNIZED THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE
ADDING THE UNITED STATES TO THE
DOZENS OF COUNTRIES THAT THEY'VE
ACQUIRED THE ATROCITIES AGAINST
ARMENIANS AN ACT OF GENOCIDE.
WILD TURKEY MAY WANT TO TURN THE
CHAPTER ON THE ARMENIAN MASSACRE
OF NINETEEN FIFTEEN THE UNITED
STATES AND CALIFORNIA. AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE NATIONAL COMMUTER
WILL NOT FORGET THIS
INTERNATIONAL CRIME AGAINST
HUMANITY. THESE ATTEMPTS
CONTINUE THE VIOLENCE CONTINUES
THE GENOCIDAL INTENT CONTINUES
AND WHAT STRUCK ME ABOUT THOSE
VILLAGERS ON THE BORDER IS THERE
NOT GOING ANYWHERE. THEY'RE
GONNA STAND ON THEIR LAND
THEY'RE GOING TO FIGHT ON THEIR
LAND AND THEY'RE GONNA DIE ON
THEIR LAND BECAUSE THEY HAVE
SOVEREIGNTY OVER THEIR FEET.
OVER THEIR HOMES OVER THEIR
CULTURE AND AS SYRIAN TURKEY
AGGRESSION ISN'T GOING TO TAKE
THAT AWAY FROM THEM. AND SO A
LINE FROM A POEM INSPIRED ME IT
SAYS WE ARE FEW. BUT WE ARE
CALLED ARMENIANS BY SUFFOLK.
GONG ET LES NINE- THERE SHOT THE
NON. WE ARE WE SHALL BE AND WE
MAY BE CUT AND WE MAY BE MANY
LET THERE BE PEACE PLEASE LET
THERE BE PEACE. ADVANCE OR NAY.
THANK YOU SIR PORTANTINO SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
OUR COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY AS
VICE CHAIR OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS
IN SUPPORT OF S. R. EIGHTY TWO-
AND IN OPPOSITION- TO GENOCIDE
DENIALISM- THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE
IS A HORROR OF HISTORY AND ONE
THAT TRAGICALLY IS ALL TOO OFTEN
EITHER IGNORED OR INTENTIONALLY
OR RACE. HISTORY HAS SHOWN US
AGAIN AND AGAIN WHAT HPPENS
WHEN WE DO NOT TAKE THE TIME TO
REMEMBER THE TRAGEDIES OF OUR
PASSED OVER ONE MILLION PEOPLE
WERE MURDERED- TO SAY NOTHING OF
THOSE EXILED FORCIBLY CONVERTED
OR OTHERWISE BRUTALIZED BY THE
OTTOMANS. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THE GENOCIDE DO NOT
JUST LIVING IN THE PAST THIS IS
NOT JUST HISTORY. GENOCIDES ARE
HAPPENING TODAY. THEY CONTINUE
TO HAPPEN YEAR AFTER YEAR. WHEN
WE ALLOW GENOCIDE TO GO ON
CHALLENGES BOTH PERPETUATES THE
VIOLENCE- SIMULTANEOUSLY DENYING
THE REALITY FELT BY THOSE
IMPACTED. AND LITERALLY ALLOWING
FOR THE AGGRESSION TO CONTINUE
ENABLING THOSE WHO MAY WANT TO
DO THE SAME. AND THEY LOOKED TO
SILENCE TO ENCOURAGE THEM TO DO
THE SAME. THE **** AS YOU JUST
HEARD LOOKED UPON THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE AS A SUCCESS. AS A
MODEL FOR THE ATROCITIES THAT
THEY WERE GOING TO COMMIT. IN
THE EXTERMINATION OF SIX MILLION
JEWS JEWS AND MILLIONS OF NON
JEWS. HILDER DIRECTLY CITED THE
FATE OF THE ARMENIANS AS A
REASON FOR WHY HIS PLAN IN
EUROPE WOULD SUCCEED. WHEN WE
DID. WHEN WE ENABLE THE DENIAL
OF THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE WE
STOKED THE FIRES OF A
HISTORICISM OF FLAME THAT BURNS
ALL OF US AND CONTINUES TO
RESULT IN THE DEATH OF PEOPLE
TODAY. WHETHER IT'S UNITED
STATES OWN DARK HISTORY WITH
RACISM IN THE ERASURE OF
INDIGENOUS PEOPLES THE HOLOCAUST
OR THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE WE MUST
HONOR THE LIVES LOST AND SPEAK
TRUTH SO THAT IT NEVER HAPPENS
AGAIN I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR WIENER SENATOR MEN
. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FROM LOS
ANGELES BY COMING OUT OF FLINT
RIDGE AND SANTA CLARITA FOR
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION
FORWARD- AS A PHILOSOPHER
SANTAYANA ONCE SAID. THOSE WHO
CANNOT REMEMBER THE PAST ARE
CONDEMNED TO REPEAT IT AND AS
HAS BEEN MENTIONED ELOQUENTLY BY
MY COLLEAGUES WE HAVE SEEN
GENOCIDES POP UP PERIODICALLY
THROUGHOUT HISTORY- WE ALWAYS
ASK OURSELVES HOW COULD THIS
HAVE HAPPENED I WORK WE'VE DONE
TO PREVENT IT AND I THINK ONE
KEY ASPECT OF THIS IS. HOPE
REMEMBERING OUR HISTORY HOLDING
ACCOUNT OF ONE IN THIS CASE
REMEMBERING THE HISTORY OF THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE BY THE OTTOMAN
EMPIRE BY THE- POPULATION IT NOW
COMPRISES TURKEY OPPORTUNITY
GIVEN THAT TURKEY HAS REFUSED TO
RECOGNIZE THIS SO I WOULD ASK ME
COOPER THIS RESOLUTION AND I
URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO VOTE I.
THANK YOU CENTER MEN SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE AND SUPPORT US
S. R. EIGHTY TWO. IT TOUCHES
HOME THE CITY OF MONTEBELLO IN
MY DISTRICT THE LARGEST MONUMENT
I THINK THAT THE ARMENIANS HAVE
DIRECTED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
GENOCIDE IN ARMENIANS COME FROM
ALL OVER THE STATE- EVERY YEAR
AS YOU'RE A KNOWLEDGE IN NOW A
HUNDRED AND SEVEN YEARS. AND I
WAS WITH THEM ON SATURDAY NIGHT
. HUNDREDS UPON HUNDREDS UPON
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE THERE. NOT
JUST ARMENIANS PEOPLE FROM IN
THE ENTIRE AREA CAME TOGETHER TO
PRAY TOGETHER AND ACKNOWLEDGE
THE SUFFERING THAT IS STILL IN
THE HEARTS OF THE DESCENDANTS
GRANDPARENTS WHO ARE NO LONGER
WITH THEM. THE ERRORS THAT ARE
HERE LIVING AND WORKING IN THE
CITY OF PICO RIVERA MY HOMETOWN
THERE'S A SMALL SCHOOL IN ITS
STARTS IN KINDERGARTEN GOES ALL
THE WAY TO HIGH SCHOOL AND IT IS
ONE OF THE MOST ESTABLISHED
ARMENIAN SCHOOLS IN THE STATE.
AND I BELIEVE IT MIGHT EVEN BE
THE FIRST AND THEIR GRADUATES
ARE ALUMNI DOCTORS LAWYERS
ENGINEERS TEACHERS CONTRACTORS
POLITICIAN YOU NAME IT THEY HAVE
SERVED OUR COUNTRY IN THE
MILITARY AS WELL. AND WHEN I
ADDRESSED THE CROWD THERE IN IN
MONTEBELLO I KNOWLEDGE. AS
AMERICANS ALL OF US STAND
TOGETHER WE WILL NEVER LET THIS
HAPPEN AGAIN. AND I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD IN IT IS TRULY
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN COME THE
GUY BEHIND AS AMERICANS AND I'M
SO PROUD THEY WERE ALL STANDING
FOR S. R. EIGHTY TWO I REGION
OF. AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SAID
ARCHULETA CENTER BOARD JUST.
COLLEAGUES I THINK. I THINK ALL
OF US HAVE WHETHER IT'S TODAY OR
IN THE PAST NUMBER OF YEARS-
HAVE EXPRESSED OUR SOLIDARITY
WITH THE ARMENIANS AND THE
ARMENIAN AMERICANS- SOME OF YOU
MAY RECALL THAT- MY- MY WIFE'S
GRANDMOTHER WAS A GENOCIDE
SURVIVOR SHE SURVIVED AS AN
EIGHT YEAR OLD THE BURNING OF
SMYRNA. BEFORE THE- THEY FOUND
REFUGE IN GREECE AND ACTUALLY
COMING OVER TO THE US BACK IN
THE SEVENTIES BUT I WAS ACTUALLY
ASKED A QUESTION RECENTLY. WHAT
DOES IT MATTER. THAT BIDEN
ACKNOWLEDGED BONTA- THAT WOULD
OCCUR WAS GENOCIDE WHAT DOES IT
MATTER WHAT CALIFORNIA. DOES IN
THIS SPACE AS WELL AND IT KIND
OF GOT ME THINKING OF FROM A
LEGAL STANDPOINT. THERE ARE WHAT
WE DO HERE IS OF REAL
SIGNIFICANCE. AND SOME OF YOU
THAT MAYBE- DID SOME WORK OR
STUDY IN INTERNATIONAL LAW MAY
RECALL A SERIES OF CASES THAT
STEMMED FROM A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT CAME FROM THIS
BODY. A NUMBER OF YEARS BACK
THAT ALLOWED SURVIVORS OF THE
GENOCIDE EIGHT YEARS OF
SURVIVORS. TO GO AFTER LIFE
INSURANCE POLICIES- FOR THOSE
LOST ONCE AND APPARENTLY THERE
WAS- THERE IS A SERIES OF CASES
CALLED- BOZTEPE AND IF I
REMEMBER CORRECTLY. AND IT WENT
ALL THE WAY THROUGH BACK AND
FORTH TO THE NINTH CIRCUIT I
THINK TWO OR THREE TIMES IN THE
ISSUE WAS. THE CALIFORNIA
INSURANCE LAW THAT ALLOWED FOR
AN EXTENSION OF THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE DESCENDANTS
OF IN EIGHT YEARS OF THOSE WHO
LOST THEIR LIVES DURING THE
GENOCIDE. EXTENDED THE STATUE
LIMITATIONS. IN THE ONE OF THE
KEY REASONS WHY THIS NINTH
CIRCUIT COURT OF APPEALS CASE
FAILED. IS BECAUSE OF FIELD
MATTER. ON OF FIELD MATTER- OVER
THE SPACE OF INTERNATIONAL
AFFAIRS WHICH IS IN THE DOMAIN
OF WASHINGTON SO THE QUESTION
THAT WAS POSED TO THE NINTH
CIRCUITIS WHAT IS AMERICA'S
POSITION ON GENOCIDE. BECAUSE IF
THERE'S AMBIGUITY AND AT THE
TIME THERE WAS IF THERE IS M. B.
UT IN THIS SPACE. THEN IT WAS A
MATTER OF A POLITICAL QUESTION
THAT DENIED THE NINTH CIRCUIT
JURISDICTION OVER THIS MATTER
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED. SO
FAST FORWARD YOU HAVE PRESIDENT
BIDEN WHO KNOWLEDGES. THAT
GENOCIDE OCCUR IN THAT HE
REACHED THE AMBIGUITY OF
AMERICA'S POSITION IN THIS
MATTER. SO I FOUND THAT VERY
INTERESTING FROM A FROM A LEGAL
ASPECT AS WE COMMEMORATE- IN
RECOGNIZE RATHER THE- WHAT WHAT
OCCURRED BETWEEN NINETEEN
FIFTEEN NINETEEN TWENTY TWO THAT
MY LAST POINT IS. THE TWO TIMES
THAT WE ALSO HAD SENATE BILLS
WERE CALIFORNIA BILLS. TO DIVEST
. THROUGH A RETIREMENT SYSTEM
INVESTMENT IN THE REPUBLIC OF
TURKEY. THAT SENDS A MESSAGE
THAT SENDS A MESSAGE TO TURKEY
THAT WE HAVE NOT FORGOTTEN THAT
WE WILL USE THE INSTRUMENTS AND
TOOLS AT OUR DISPOSAL TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT HISTORY IS PROPERLY
WRITTEN. THE COLLEAGUES I JUST
WANTED TO BRING THAT THAT THAT
SMALL SIDE- STORY TOO WHAT IS A
- DARK CHAPTER IN WORLD HISTORY
ONE THAT MATTERS OBVIOUSLY A LOT
TO US INTERNALLY TO MY FAMILY
AND- THOROUGHLY. WHICH WERE
EVERYONE TO SUPPORT THIS SENATE
BILL RESOLUTION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR BARGES MEMBERS IS THERE
ANY MORE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
SENATE RESOLUTION EIGHTY TO. A
MORE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING
NONE SENATOR DRAWS A WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK RELIABLE THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT THANK YOU
CENTER DRAWS A MEMBERS THIS ALSO
QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION. TO
USING ANIMALS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM SEEING NON. RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. IS THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS
ZERO. NUMBERS WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ONTO CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE
ONE ITEM ON CONSENT. DOES ANY
MEMBER WISH TO PULL THAT ITEM.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BAKER I PORCHES I BRADFORD.
CABALLERO I PROTECTING AYE
DIALING AYE DODD I YOU'RE
AWESOME I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG I
WESTERN. HER DAUGHTER I JONES I
KAMLAGER I LAYERED I LEYVA I
LIMON I MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S
AYE MIN AYE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN.
I A CHILL OF BOTH. I PAN I
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE
SKINNER HI STERN HI I'M BURKE
AYE AYE CASKEY AYE WIENER AYE
WILK. MEMBERS RUN GO THROUGH THE
ROLE ONE MORE TIME- TO PICK UP
THE ABSENT MEMBERS- PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD
GROWTH WESSEL I WILL.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BRADFORD I GROVE WELL. HIGHS
THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS IS ZERO
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WERE
GONNA MOVE BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS IF WE CAN GIVE OUR
ATTENTION TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PLEASE WE'RE GONNA MOVE INTO A
GERMAN MEMORY WE'RE GOING TO
RECOGNIZE SENATOR DODD FOR
TODAY'S ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT
. I IT'S WITH THE- HEAVY HEART
THAT IRISE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
OF JOHN DUNLAP A FORMER SENATOR
FOR THE NORTH BAY ONE OF OUR OWN
WHOSE FAMILY IS UP ABOVE TODAY.
JOHN WAS BORN IN SEPTEMBER
ELEVENTH NINETEEN TWENTY TWO IN
GREW UP ON THE DUNLAP FAMILY
PRUNE RANCH IN YACHT BILL. JOHN
ATTENDED NAPA HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATING IN NINETEEN FORTY. HE
SERVED FOUR YEARS THE ARMY AIR
CORPS FOR. IN A DIRT DURING THE
SECOND WORLD WAR AFTER THE WAR
HE EARNED HIS DEGREE AT UC
BERKELEY AND WENT ON TO LAW
SCHOOL AT UC HASTINGS. HE CAME
FROM A LONG WIDER PUBLIC
SERVANTS THE KROONSTAD LET
FAMILY A HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR
YEAR HISTORY OF LEGISLATIVE
SERVICE BEGAN WITH JOHN'S GREAT
GRANDFATHER NATHAN KUNZ. IN FACT
HE ALSO FOUNDED THE CITY OF NAPA
IN EIGHTEEN FORTY SEVEN. AND
SERVED TWO TERMS IN THE ASSEMBLY
. JOHN'S GREAT UNCLE FRANK L.
KUN SERVE THE ASSEMBLY FROM.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SIX TO NINETEEN
THIRTY. AN UNCLE NATHAN F.
COOMBS REPRESENT NAPA COUNTY IN
THE SENATE FROM. NINETEEN FORTY
EIGHT TO NINETEEN SIXTY JOHN
SERVED IN THE ASSEMBLY. FROM.
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT TO NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR AND THEN THE SENATE
FROM NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR TO
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT ALL OF
JOHN'S ANCESTORS WERE
REPUBLICANS WITH JOHN BEING THE
ONLY DEMOCRAT. I WON'T COMMENT
ANY FURTHER ON THAT. BUT WHAT A
GREAT GUY JOHN'S HOME IN NAPA
WITH THE SETTING WHEN THE LATE
ENVIRONMENTALIST BILL QUORUM IN
OTHERS CONCEIVED THE IDEA FOR
PROPOSITION TWENTY WHICH WITH
ITS NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO BALLOT
MEASURE THEY CREATEDTHE STATE
COASTAL COMMISSION AND TOOK
CONTROL SEASIDE DEVELOPMENT AWAY
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. THE
MEASURE WAS BACKED BY THEN
SECRETARY OF STATE JERRY BROWN
IN APPROVED BY 55% OF THE
STATE'S VOTERS. TODAY JOHN IS
REGARDED AS A PIONEER AND A
VISIONARY AND SUPPORTING FARM
WORKER RIGHTS AND PROTECTING THE
ENVIRONMENT. HE WORK WITH
GOVERNOR BROWN TO PASS A
NINETEEN SEVENTY LAW THAT
CREATED THE AGRICULTURE LABOR
RELATIONS BOARD WHICH ESTABLISH
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING RIGHTS FOR
FARMWORKERS DURING A TIME WERE
FARMWORKERS RIGHTS WERE NOT SO
POPULAR. JOHN IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE MARY LOU HIS CHILDREN JANE
DUNLAP OF ST PAUL MINNESOTA.
PETER DUNLAP OF PETALUMA- I
DAVID DUNLAP OF NAPA JILL DUNLAP
GOALLESS OF SANTA ROSA HIS
DAUGHTER IN LAW MARGARET DUNLAP
OF PETALUMA AND HIS SON IN LAW
P. GOES OF SANTA ROSA. AS WELL
AS FIVE GRANDCHILDREN AND FIVE
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. YOU KNOW
IT'S A POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE I DID GET TO KNOW THE
CENTER OF WAY BEFORE I GOT INTO
POLITICS- GOING OUT TO HIS HOUSE
AND BEING HIS WATER GUY. AND
WORKING ON AS WELL IT WOULDN'T
BE IT'S JUST SOMETHING THAT'S
ALWAYS THE BEES ME ABOUT HOW
SMART. THOUGHTFUL HONEST. AND
HUMBLE MAN HE WAS BUT ALSO WITH
A GREAT WIT AND SENSE OF HUMOR-
JUST ABSOLUTELY AMAZING HUMAN
BEING- I PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
JOURNEY THE SENATE SESSION IN
MEMORY OF A GREAT AMERICAN. A
GREAT CALIFORNIA AND ONE OF OUR
OWN SENATOR JOHN DUNLAP. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR DODD
SENATOR NIELSEN ON THIS ITEM. MR
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
THE SENATE. I'M VERY HONORED TO
BE ABLE TO RECOGNIZE JOHN DUNLAP
HERE TODAY AS WE JOIN IN HIS
MEMORY. HE IS INDEED A MEMORABLE
MAN. FROM THE POLITICAL DYNASTY
FROM NAPA COUNTY. IT'S NOT
INCONSISTENT THAT JOHN MIGHT
HAVE DEPARTED FROM HIS
PREDECESSORS IN THIS FAMILY AND
BECAME A DEMOCRAT. JOHN HAD THAT
INDEPENDENT STREAK. WHEN WE RUN
AGAINST OTHER EACH OTHER IN
SEVENTY NINE. I ADMIRED SO MUCH
THAT HE HAD BEEN A LITTLE BIT
OUT OF TOUCH WITH THE AREA TO BE
REPRESENTED HE CARRIED ON
AUTHORED THE AGRICULTURAL LABOR
RELATIONS ACT. THAT DISTRICT WAS
VERY HEAVILY AGRICULTURAL THAT
WAS NOT A POPULAR STAND TO TAKE
IN THAT COUNTY. THAT DID NOT
DETER JOHN DUNLAP ONE WHAT. HE
CARRIED THAT. LEGISLATION
PROUDLY. AND THAT LEGISLATION
LIVES ON YET TODAY. THE
AGRICULTURAL LABOR RELATIONS
BOARD GOVERNS THAT ACT. THE DAY
AUTHORED. HE ALSO CARRIED MANY
ENVIRONMENTAL BILLS AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM NAPA OF THE
KNOWLEDGE MAJOR BILLS. THAT WAS
NOT ALSO ONE OF THE MORE POPULAR
THEMES. IN THOSE DAYS. NOR WAS
HIS POSITION ON CRIMINAL JUSTICE
. BUT JOHN IS A MAN OF TRUE
CONVICTION. AN IDEA WITH THE
RECIPIENT EARLY ON OF MY CAREER
OF HIS WIT. ELECTION NIGHT HE
CALLED ME. AND I WAS VERY
GRACIOUS. AND I RESPONDED CENTER
DUNLAP I WOULD CERTAINLY LIKE TO
AVAIL MYSELF OF YOUR WISDOM AND
ALL OF YOUR YEARS. ANY CAME BACK
QUICKLY SAID WELL JIM YOU AND
PAYING ATTENTION TO WHAT I SAID
ANYWAY. WELL THAT ISN'T
NECESSARILY SELL BECAUSE
SKIPPING FORWARD MANY YEARS I
WAS DEEPLY HONORED TO RECEIVE A
CALL FROM SENATOR DUNLAP.
INVITING ME TO COME AND SPEAK AT
HIS POLITICAL SCIENCE CLASS AT
NAPA COLLEGE. AND I COULDN'T
HEAP ENOUGH PRAISE ON THE MAN.
WE MAY HAVE DIFFERED POLITICALLY
. BUT I NEVER QUESTIONED HIS
INTEGRITY NEVER QUESTION HIS
COMMITMENT FEALTY TO HIS BELIEFS
THOSE CORE BELIEFS THE COSTUME
SOMETIMES TO BE OUT OF PART WITH
OTHER PEOPLE IN HIS OWN FAMILY
AND- SOMETIMES IN THE
LEGISLATURE. BUT THAT WAS DONE
THE WAY. HE LIVED A VERY
PRODUCTIVE LIFE ALMOST IN ONE
HUNDRED YEARS OLD. AND WE MADE
IT A POINT TO STAY IN TOUCH FROM
TIME TO TIME. AND I WOULD CALL
THIS DAUGHTER AND ASK IF WOULD
BE OKAY FOR ME TO CALL JOHN AND-
CHAT WITH HIM. AND HE WAS ALWAYS
VERY GRACIOUS WOULD TAKE THE
CALL. THAT TAUGHT ME A LOT.
ABOUT WHAT THE SENATE WAS ABOUT
. NICER MOST OF HIS YEARS IN THE
ASSEMBLY BUT THE HEAD OF ONE
FULL TERM IN THE SENATE HE KNEW
WHAT THE SENATE WAS ALL ABOUT.
IT WAS ABOUT BIPARTISANSHIP. THE
COURTESY AND RESPECT. HE
CERTAINLY CARRIED HIMSELF IN
THAT MANNER IN THIS INSTITUTION
. WE SHOULD BE VERY PROUD TO
RECOGNIZE SENATOR JOHN DUNLAP
HERE TODAY AS WE ADJOURN IN HIS
HONOR. REGRESSED GODSPEED TO HIS
FAMILY AS THEY CARRY ON THAT
POLITICAL FAMILY IN NAPA COUNTY.
GOD LOVE JOHN DUNLAP. THANK YOU
SIR NIELSEN CENTER LAYERED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT
AND I THINK IT'S INTERESTING
BECAUSE LISTENING TO THE TALKS
HERE ARE JUST A FEW PEOPLE THAT
KNEW HIM HE HAS NOT BEEN IN THE
SENATE IN FORTY FOUR YEARS.A
AND HE HAD SUCH PERSONAL
LONGEVITY AND POLITICAL
LONGEVITY THE DESPITE MORE
HONORABLE CALLING FROM NAPA WHO
FOCUSED ON THE NAPA PART HE ALSO
REPRESENTED VALLEJO AND SOLANO
COUNTY AND HI I WAS IN HIGH
SCHOOL IN VALLEJO. WHEN JOHN
DUNLAP WAS OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND A LOT OF US WERE. THAT'S
SCHOOL STUDENTS ABOUT TO GO
UNDER COLLEGE CONCERNED ABOUT A
PARTICULAR FOREIGN INVOLVEMENT
THE UNITED STATES HAD AT THE
TIME. AND HE CAME AND MET WITH
US AND HE CAME AND TALKED TO
ASSIDUOUS CEREBRAL HE WAS HONEST
AS WAS SAID HE WAS HUMOROUS. AND
I THINK HE WAS GOING TO TALK TO
ANYBODY AND TRY TO WORK THEM
THROUGH THE ISSUE. N. AS WAS
SAID I MEAN HE WAS A WAITER ON
THE COASTAL COMMISSION. THAT ACT
IS CELEBRATING FIFTY TWO YEARS
AND I KNOW WHEN THERE WAS A
FIFTY YEAR ANNIVERSARY HE WAS
ONE OF THE FEW PEOPLE THAT WAS
AN AUTHOR OF THAT TO STILL BE
AROUND AND I'M GLAD THAT HE HAD
THE CHANCE. WHILE HE WAS ALIVE
TO BE APPRECIATED FOR. AND
HERE'S SOMETHING THAT WE I THINK
SOMETIMES LOSE IN POLITICS.
WHICH IS UP TO BE EVEN HANDED
FRIENDLY USE THEIR WEB TO MAKE A
POINT WE'LL TALK TO EVERYBODY
WE'LL WORK THROUGH AN ISSUE. AND
THE WORD HONORABLE TO AND USED
IN FRONT OF ALL OUR NAMES ALL
THE TIME. REALLY FITS HIM AND
FIT HIM AS AN ELECTED OFFICIAL
AND AS A HUMAN BEING AND SO I AM
PROUD. TO RISE AND ADJOURNED IN
HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU SIR LET
MEMBERS WE ARE JOINED TODAY IN
THE GALLERY BY MEMBERS OF THE
DUNLOP FAMILY IF THEY CAN BE
USED AS STAND BE RECOGNIZED THIS
THIS AFTERNOON. AND IF- THE
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE CAN. GIVE
PROPER HONOR TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE FAMILY. THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE RECOGNIZES YOUR SERVICE
YOUR FAMILY SERVICE TO OUR STATE
AND OUR COUNTRY WE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US HERE
TODAY. GOD BLESS YOU. MEMBERS IF
THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS-
TODAY CENTER ATKINS THE DESK IS
CLEAR. MR PRESIDENT THANKS SO
MUCH COLLEAGUES- OUR NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR THIS
THURSDAY APRIL TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AT NINE AM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR RECKONS
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME
THE GERMAN MOTION WILL BE MADE
SORRY WE WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY
AT NINE AM MEMBERS HAVE A
PRODUCTIVE WEEK WE'LL SEE YOU
BACK HERE. ON THURSDAY.